so i just want to start by saying hello
and thank you so much for having me it's
a real pleasure to be
back here at stanford i grew up in the
bay area and have long time stanford
connections and worked at ideo for many
years right down downtown palo alto
so it's really a pleasure to be here
talking about design
and i think kind of bringing like
michael was saying a practice-based
perspective
back to a conversation about
human-centered computing
and hci type work um so i wanted to
start just by framing
i guess the broad brush strokes of what
an engineering degree or practice ought
to be
typically we define engineering as the
application
of science to addressing human needs and
in the university environment for sure
typically what that means
is that you'll spend about 99 of your
resources on engineering science
right and the assumption
is that if you have a very good
scientific kind of research
critical thinking kind of tool set that
will be a very useful thing
when you go out into the world to
engineer things
here at stanford the
computer science department is within an
engineering school
and you've got uh you know human
computer interaction
which is very much focused on human
needs and there's a certain way of
thinking about
thinking about human needs in the
context of an engineering program
the question that i've got is you know
that basically
the usefulness of needs to engineering
really requires deeply understanding
what humans need
and if you're spending 99 of your
resources on a scientific kind of
research based
perspective who's really responsible for
this stuff
who should be responsible for this stuff
typically the way that most engineering
programs
will focus that is by saying well that
must be scientists
scientists who study human needs and
that makes good sense because scientists
are smart
and they have strong perspectives on the
world um but
if you actually think about it clearly
you've got the sciences and then you've
got
well the humanities right you would
think the humanities would be
the discipline interested in human needs
unfortunately
um i don't know most engineers don't
want to be told what to do by
the humanities right because engineering
is a kind of very legitimate technical
field
um and so what ends up happening is that
you get scientists who are
um i don't know you can start to think
about like where where does the money
come from for the research or how is it
being funded or who's in charge of kind
of understanding which things should be
engineered
should it be politicians right maybe
it's people at nsf
right whose job it is to fund research
in engineering
and it's their job to kind of figure out
which director it would be most
appropriate for advancing
human needs in engineering and that
seems
reasonable um but of course you know
what's actually going on here is that
the people who are at nsf
are former engineers who are leaders in
engineering right and they're the ones
who get to think
broadly about what the future of the
field should be
these are people that i would like to
call designers so the reality is that
pretty much anyone who's doing
engineering
or anyone who's doing research for that
matter is a
particular kind of designer they're an
engineering designer or computer science
designer
they're designing computer systems they
might not be trained as designers in a
kind of classical
practice based sense though so one of
the things i want to talk to
about today is just um you know the
history of human-centered design and
kind of where it's going
and there's a deep history of
integration between human needs and
engineering
most recently we've talked talked about
this as human centered design
in hci work as a scientific
research discipline human factors has
generally been what we call
the discipline that studies how humans
interact with their environment with the
aim of
improving the safety and quality of
human experiences interacting with
technology
and you know if you go to the kai
conference it is still the acm
conference on human factors and
computing systems
okay human factors has a deep history
going back
at least to the industrial revolution at
which point you know this is charlie
chaplin in modern times which if you
haven't seen that's a kind of classic
silent film on the modernization of
industry
and sort of the dehumanizing qualities
that that brought to
uh people who are now going to work in
factories and kind of the disruption
that that had
on the sort of you know the craftsman or
the guild or the you know the people who
who prior to that had you know small
kind of boutique shops or whatever
um so you know during the industrial
revolution there really wasn't a lot of
attention paid to
humanizing technology or thinking about
design in that way
until during the second world war
we had such a rapid advance in the way
in which technology was being engineered
that airplanes would show up at the
front lines which pilots didn't know how
to fly
because the technology was was advancing
and kind of innovating so quickly
um this is a photoshop uh a photo from a
manual
of a fighter plan in world war ii and it
actually led to huge amounts of
fatalities right like pilots literally
didn't know how to control these things
they couldn't fly them they couldn't
land them it's very dangerous
and so there's this new field born
around human factors engineering really
starting to understand hey there's a
human in the loop controlling this plane
we need to make it at the very least
operable
right and then you know as time
progressed after that
we find ourselves with digital
technology right in the
70s and then into the 80s we have user
interfaces happening
and this is where usability becomes a
big concern it's no longer
life-threatening
the plane's not going to crash but it's
really really frustrating i don't know
how to
i don't know how to save my email or
whatever it might be
so that's been kind of the history of
human computer interaction has
has basically been getting psychologists
and other kinds of scientists interested
in understanding human behavior
integrated into engineering research to
make things safer more usable
on the flip side there's also a history
of design
and design has always been a kind of
human-centered discipline right so
these are photos from raymond loewy who
was an industrial designer working in
the
uh 30s and 40s primarily and you know he
was doing a lot to sort of humanize
technology in a different way thinking
about how does it make you feel right
kind of can we skin it we'll make it
more aesthetically interesting uh has
something to do with kind of styling has
something to do with advertising
you see you know we're making machines
and we're making them feel like they're
faster feel like
there's something that i want to own or
consume
then we know charles and ray eames who
um kind of took it a step further they
really started integrating
human-centered methodologies into the
way in which manufacturing processes
happened
um and and started thinking about making
objects but also really
really much broader visions about the
future of the world and how people
should cooperate together they made a
lot of instructional educational films
and really did a wonderful job of kind
of pioneering the human-centeredness of
design in a more kind of
consumer-facing personal one-on-one
relationship that you might have with a
brand
um this is henry dreyfus um another
human factors engineer sort of designer
who's pretty famous for this work he did
on the measure of man looking at kind of
average heights heights and distances
and movement and
degrees of freedom of kind of the
average american man and woman
and build a whole book specking out all
of those things which would help
designers and engineers make better
working environments for them
to uh to live in and then of course more
recently we have human-centered design
it's really gone very commercial there's
been a whole
sort of methodology that's grown out of
many places
including the product design program
here it's been commercialized at places
like ideo and lots of consulting firms
all across the world and then even more
recently we have kind of
it's no longer about human-centered uh
making just of products
but actually the whole process or
service platform by which one does
consulting work
has become a product in its own right
right so now we're selling
design thinking and design processes to
people who can kind of read a cookbook
on how to practice
human-centered design by following the
steps and applying in their own life
okay so i'm going to talk very quickly
about human-centered design just kind of
frame
frame where the discipline is now and
then i want to spend the rest of the
talk today
kind of looking at the future of what
i'm going to call post-human-centered
design
and this has been an area that i've been
thinking about since really i got
involved in
robotics research several years ago when
i was doing my phd work
thinking about i don't know if we're
going to be thinking about
human centeredness and applying it to
technology
particularly at this really kind of
critical moment in human evolution where
technology has become so
fundamental to all of our interactions
with pretty much everything um
and when we're kind of on the verge of
new kinds of technology that will have
kind of sentient you know autonomous
intelligent life
right we should start to be thinking
about sort of well post-human factors
right post-human centered design what's
coming next
what's after human-centered design and
how can we design for the people who
don't exist yet
for the post-humans how can we make
experiences for them
so human-centered design as practiced
today is typically broken into these
phases we've got need finding
form giving and communication or
implementation of some kind
design as a discipline for the most part
is about envisioning a future and kind
of
pointing the way uh maybe specifying how
something should get implemented
and then allowing someone else to do the
kind of delivery and manufacturing
or development of that process so at a
place like ideo
um you've probably seen many diagrams
that look something like this but
basically you have
a need finding phase up front which is
about understanding observing and
synthesizing data from real people
then you have a form giving you know and
here we're rapidly prototyping and
iterating and evaluating and refining
our design
and then at the end we sort of you know
we see what we learned
we iterate a few more times we wrap that
all up communicate what we found
and somebody will take it and implement
it or build it
at ideo these are typically broken into
phases like this so
you know when they were just starting
out as a kind of product design
engineering shop
they were doing a lot of manufacturing
work and then you know their their big
differentiator was around
coming up with new concepts for how to
solve problems and
building rapid prototypes and showing
them to people and getting feedback uh
today probably you know 98
of the work that they do is in this
first phase zero space which is really
about going much deeper
into designing what the problem is
thinking strategically about how to
solve it
doing some ethnographic research going
in the field synthesizing your findings
identifying opportunity areas generating
principles for design
building an opportunity framework like
where is this project going to go kind
of reframing the project
to make sure you're aligned and then
you'll generate your concepts brainstorm
prototype
do some preliminary design work evaluate
validate iterate
and then at the end if the project even
gets here a lot of times this work
happens in-house or overseas or
shopped out to a vendor there'll be
engineering
cost analysis development work and all
of that to make the thing real
stepping away from this you can think
kind of broadly about what's happening
here
the idea that in the phase zero this
first phase really what we're doing in
the project is we're making something
that's useful
okay so we're thinking about what is it
that people want
how is our design going to really
improve and enhance their life in some
way that's meaningful
and we're going to design that this
middle phase is kind of where a lot of
this history of
of the human factors work is much more
about ergonomics or usability right
we've got to design we just need to make
sure that it's functional right i can
accomplish the tasks that i need to do
it's a tool that works for me i can get
the job done
and here in the late phase i can make
things delightful
so this is kind of back to raymond
loewy's work right i can take a
locomotive
and i can skin it in a way that makes it
look fast right or i can make a product
and i can package it in a way that makes
it feel like something i want to consume
but at this point the useful work and
the usable work has already happened
and the best the designer can hope to do
is kind of make it delightful and that's
why traditionally
when designers have been asked to solve
problems really late in the phase
a design is really prevented from being
more useful or usable than it was to
begin with
and that kind of perpetuates the idea
that design is about superficial
aesthetics and styling
right so if you have a designer has all
these strategic skills and you put them
in
a company like microsoft and they have
to design all the icons for powerpoint
for the 50th time because there keeps
being a reorg right they're not they're
not delivering the strategic value that
they could
the best they can do is make cute icons
that make people smile but it's not
really changing the usability
or the usefulness of the tool in the
first place
and what we really want from design is
usefulness right we want to make things
that make the world better
and that's why this new finding phase is
really critical need finding applies to
all areas of design practice
or research typically in design practice
that's
you know product design physical
physical products branding strategy work
all of those will benefit from kind of
contextualizing research
and a good deep empathy for what people
really need
and in consumer industries this is
really important just because it's so
expensive to be designing the wrong
thing right it's very expensive to
engineer products
very competitive marketplace everybody
is you know trying to capture eyeballs
quickly online with their new app
and if you're building the wrong thing
or you miss it by a couple weeks or
there's a release of something else
just at the wrong time it can be pretty
much the death of your company
okay so basically the point from human
center design is it's really essential
that when we apply this methodology
we're using it to work on the right
design problem
and we're getting as early into the into
the field talking to real people
understanding real needs as we can to
make the most strategic value
okay so now i want to look at the future
and what might be coming next so
just a definition uh posthuman i'm not
sure how many of you have heard this
term
this has been kind of kicking around in
the kind of theory literature for some
time
many of you have probably heard of
post-modernism right so we had modernism
and then we had kind of you know late
modernism and then
that kind of became postmodern sometime
in the 70s and 80s and everything got
radically kind of decontextualized and
very subjective
um and people were thinking a lot about
kind of power relationships and
structuring of information in the
computerized age
it's what happens after modernism
posthumanism takes a similar kind of
critical
theoretical look at what happens after
the human
and particularly thinking about what
happens when the technologies that we
have become
so deeply integrated into what it means
to be human that all of our sort of
humanist
values everything that we consider to be
humanism
no longer applies um and
the basic capacities of these future
humans
so radically exceed those of present
humans that we can't really consider
them to be human
by our current standards so for example
here we have a human
right this is an ordinary human and they
live quite happily
and then maybe i don't know
20 years ago a bunch of things started
to change right
we got computers then the internet now
we have mobile devices
virtual environments augmented reality
machine intelligence genetic engineering
organ transplants designer drugs
right many of these things were very
disruptive at first i'm sure in the 70s
if you've got a heart transplant
right that's like ethically quite
dubious it's you know not yet fully
approved we don't know if it's safe
is that totally creepy now it's like
standard practice right we've got
you drive up 101 there's a huge like
like oregon
oregon transplant center and they're
shipping people in from all over the
world and putting organs on ice
and that's completely normal this is
what the
post-humanist philosophers call the
transhuman
and we are all now trans humans we're
living in this transitional moment
between being human and being something
else
and those technologies are changing us
and what's coming next
and it's not hard to imagine if you look
at science fiction or
you do research in this space is that
computers are getting faster and faster
we're going to have autonomous robots
performing more and more manual tasks
and intelligence tasks
uh we're looking at technologies like
like life extension maybe you can live
forever just keep swapping out the
organs forever or you'll become kind of
cyborg right you'll get a
cyborg i don't know cochlear implant
it's basically it's a bionic ear
right we're thinking even about once we
have super intelligence right
maybe you can upload your mind into the
cloud and just like live in a virtual
reality space
you can design your own children think
about artificial life colonize space
simulate yourself and determine what
kind of drug you should take to live
longer or be happier
yeah so these theories don't really
posit that human that humanness can
slide that is what's currently
considered human
may have been may have been
post-human-like in many ways
a thousand years ago like we could solve
diseases sure we could access
information just uh yes the tip of our
fingers like these are these are
very big differences yeah it's
significantly different
yes even i mean in in the world of
theory
everything is a theory right so it's all
hypothesis but you know it's fair to say
whether we call ourselves
we're in modernism or we're in
post-modernism maybe post-modernism is
just a very high form of modernism
as far as humanism goes something is
definitely changing
because yeah okay so i i buy the
the the you know all theories are wrong
some are interesting that that line
sure i get it uh this particular
transition then
what you know what is different from
this transition compared to say what
like vanner bush was thinking
when he was like okay um
so i think what's happening here is in
theory the post-human
is really no longer human so it doesn't
resemble anything that could have
happened without humanity intervening in
itself
in a way which is really pretty
extremely different than the past and
the reason it's different has to do with
evolution
humans are designed by nature if you
will we
evolved over millions of years in
response to our environment and we can
say that maybe evolution is speeding up
but evolution is shifting into a space
of silicon into a space of
the digital the transhuman is designed
by humans
right and we've seen that design has
become a really major deal
right we have engineering of pretty much
anything look around
right there is nothing that we interact
with apart from nature in a state park
somewhere
maybe that hasn't been designed by
humans
and increasingly even our environment
like everything is designed by humans
right
the posthuman is is unique in the sense
that it's post-evolutionary
right so if you became an organ an
organism which
could choose you know basically design
all of its children before they were
born
by a chance right could simulate itself
and determine how best to survive
could multiply itself across lots of
bodies could upload its mind into the
cloud and
put it into another body we've really
exceeded the limitations of our
kind of mechanical our mechanical
limitations and we've moved into
a purely kind of digital platform for
life
which is pretty significantly different
and there's tons of theory here and it's
very controversial and much of it is
kind of wackadoo science stuff
and much of it is also quite compelling
to be thinking about kind of
strategically about what's coming
i don't know i think i think a lot of
times science fiction and kind of
speculative research
does a lot to ask important questions
about
whether that's a future we want to live
in or not and a lot of times there's a
big disconnect between
the scientific fact and the popular
perception right cloning is really
dangerous genetic
engineering is really bad for the crops
right
scientific story is much more
complicated than that but it gets the
discussion happening in public and
people start thinking really seriously
about what kind of future do i want my
kids to grow up in
right what's the future of our planet
going to be if you
look at this you'll see that there's
really this huge convergence of
technologies happening this century
right probably in the next 20 years
we've got biotech nanotech
infotech cognitive science all coming
together in a pretty radical way
and what it's effectively doing is
making new kinds of life so
if i'm a kind of biological human and i
have new nanotechnology or new robot
technology
i'm becoming a cyborg right right now
we're already all cyborgs right we're
effectively soft cyborgs
we live in an internet of things
connected to the cloud with our google
glass
and our fitbit and our phone in our
pocket right these are essentially
extending us into a software space
we've got ubiquitous computing pervasive
computing
we are cyborgs okay then you've got
nanotechnology
combining with info technology and
you've got lots of people coming up with
well we can effectively make lots of
little micro swarming robots and they
can have sensors on them and we can drop
them from airplanes or we can
we can fly drones all over the place
right we're effectively building new
kinds of artificial life
there may be fundamental kinds of life
they're about as smart as an insect or a
cockroach
or maybe a rodent but over time those
are going to become increasingly alive
and we can start to consider them as
such in the infotech space we've
effectively got simulated life right we
can run the entire population we can run
simcity on our computer
right and we can make a whole simulated
city of people who are doing stuff or a
whole simulated ant colony
that effectively behaves like an ant
because the program has that many
neurons
in its code then we've got the idea of
meta life
so i don't know you could this this gets
kind of metaphorical but you could kind
of think about it like
right now in your brain right there's a
whole lot of neurons
and they've got synapses and they're
firing electrical pulses and each neuron
is quite content and quite alive just as
one little cell
doing what it does talk to the other
neurons we
are now all living in a kind of
environment here where
we're sort of like the neurons right we
all communicate with each other we live
in our little bubble we go to work
we upload stuff to the internet and
we've got we've got this kind of
meta consciousness coming online right
the internet
could switch on and start to pay
attention so it's a new kind of meta
life it's hard hard for us to see it
because it's in a whole different
paradigm space
um but but the point here is that we're
entering this really pretty radically
different kind of post-human existence
where we've got cyborgs artificial life
simulated life metalife
all kind of coming online and
interacting in really interesting
unexpected ways
i feel like this slide could have
existed about 20 years ago
yes and i'm wondering what's changed why
now
um so sure from a research perspective
it's true i think i think why now is
that it's in the public imagination in a
much more real way
these changes are now we're getting
we're getting all the stuff on
kickstarter we're getting updates all
the time from our app
you know from our app store we've got
people dropping out of high school to
make
you know to make crazy things that are
doing incredible stuff we've got
artificial intelligence happening
i think it's just becoming much more
pervasive and it's becoming exponential
that's all
we're on an exponential curve and and
the point is basically just that the
paradigm shift rate for technology
change we've got moore's law
right so whatever it is every every two
or three years
the amount of space on our silicon chip
doubles and we've got more and more
computational power
and it can be really hard for us to
envision that from our current point in
time
because all we really have to reflect on
is a linear view of the past
and when we look at our clock it's
ticking at the same speed
so typically humans when we think about
our past right
we've got this intuitively kind of
linear view of our exponential history
so just for example in 1990 some
biochemists had
transcribed about a 10 000th of the
human genome
and given their rate of progress at the
time the experts in the field of
genetics predicted that it would take
or it could take up to 100 years to
complete and that was accomplished in
under 15 years
here's ray kurzweil famous futurist and
crackpot scientist
depending if you like him or not but
he's drawing on a lot of pretty robust
kind of empirical studies of
computational power keeps doubling right
so we won't experience 100 years of
technological advance in the 21st
century
we will witness on the order of 20 000
years of progress
when measured by today's rate of
progress or about a thousand times
greater
than that was achieved in the 20th
century
that's pretty phenomenal here's growth
in supercomputer power
on our logarithmic graph okay it's now
the year 2015 when i first did this talk
it was 2010
and there's been several new
supercomputers since then
kurzweil argues that what is required
for what he calls functional brain
simulation
is whatever this is 10 to the 15th uh
floating point operations per second
in terms of super supercomputer power
now this says nothing about the software
that your brain is running so when he
says functional simulation of the brain
he basically means there's enough there
to model
the kinds of in ins and outs of say the
hippocampus
the visual cortex all the different
parts of the brain unfortunately
neuroscience is nowhere near
deep enough along the way to fully
understand how all that stuff is wired
but the point here is just we have raw
computational power and you know within
some amount of time to get the design
right
we could be running a functional
simulation of the human brain
by 2013 which is two years ago for human
brain
neural simulation the required
computational power would be equivalent
in 2025
to basically build a simulation model of
every molecule in every neuron
in every synapse in the human brain
which is pretty phenomenal and if you
look forward from that
you can basically do the same
calculation uh
by dividing the cost in half every year
so that by the year 2045
we would have human equivalent personal
computer for two dollars
okay that's 30 years away it's coming
fast
and you know frankly by the year 2030 it
would cost
probably half what your laptop cost
today
okay now let's look at the world
population okay we've got
by recent estimates about seven billion
people on the planet
and you know people think that's going
to trail off at some point
probably as we get to the end of the
century but we're adding in
all of these super computer people right
no matter how you look at it right this
is what this is what the future is
called the singularity right
infinite population by the year 2045. of
course you know
what really is the difference between
having two billion
and having infinite billion right maybe
not a whole lot if our social and kind
of political systems haven't changed
but it matters a lot in the sense that
we need to understand
how that computation will affect the
rights of individual humans to vote
or the ability of individual humans to
perform the work that they need to do or
to communicate with others
right the distribution of that
technology is going to be a very
important issue
if current accelerations in computer
power continue to increase at their
current rates we will have a singularity
by the year 2045
as humanity will have created seemingly
infinite computational power
um many futurists hope that the earth's
ecosystem will be transformed into this
computer-controlled technogaian utopia
and it will all kind of balance itself
out we're living in the clouds
everything is taken care of we have
infinite resources solar power
and everybody's happy and people will
upload their minds into this eternal
simulation of pure fantasy and live
forever
in silicon wafers but clearly
whatever happens to get to whatever
state that's going to be we're going to
face some pretty profound challenges
uh human intelligence will effectively
be obsolete
you know the tools that we have maybe
the software running the social
structures we have will be in place
but the intelligence itself will no
longer be relevant
okay economic wealth is already frankly
in a bank
right but it will be entirely in the
hands of super intelligent machines
okay they'll make the decisions on where
to invest they'll make decisions on
what to to do presuming we manage to
survive at all and it's likely that the
people who do end up at the very tippy
top
will be the ones who control those super
computers and have all them the wealth
already
so the point here is just that there's
numerous existential and ethical risks
coming we don't know what they all are
but we have to confront them and we
should start thinking about them
if we're really interested in human
centered design right the future of
humans
let's think about things that can go
wrong okay
there's a guy at oxford named nick
bostrom who's done a ton of really good
post-humanism work and he wrote an
excellent paper on
the existential risks which this draws
from basically what he's saying is
you know if you have a personal risk
that's endurable like your car gets
stolen
or you get killed okay that
is still you know it's not endurable to
you it's terminal
but it's kind of local in scope right
here's a slightly bigger local scope you
know there's a recession
and everybody loses their job or there's
genocide
right permanent enslavement everybody is
uh
is pretty much taken out right that's
not good
uh here's the thinning of the ozone
layer it affects everyone everywhere
right it's endurable but it's global an
existential risk
is in this top category it's something
that's global and something that's
terminal
and the scary thing is that many of
these are being created by us right now
an existential risk is defined as one
where an adverse outcome would either
annihilate earth originating intelligent
life
or permanently and drastically curtail
its potential okay
so the issue here and it's very
different than human centered design or
engineering practice today
is that existential risks don't give you
a second chance if you're wrong
you can't do rapid iteration and
prototyping with existential risks it
doesn't work
right for there to be a risk given the
knowledge and understanding available
it suffices that there's some subjective
probability of an adverse
outcome our only possible course of
action is to examine possible future
scenarios
and use our best current subjective
estimate
on what the objective risk factors may
be even if later we determine that some
of them are objectively impossible we
don't know whether something is
objectively risky or not
then it's risky in the subjective sense
and the only thing we can do
is base our decisions on that subjective
reality because we can't make a mistake
okay consider this this plot let's
imagine that the
technological potential of humanity is
getting stronger and
what's called the cultural potential is
getting stronger okay and right now
we're in this sort of humanist space
moving into the transhuman space heading
towards posthumanity and
uploading into the cosmic mind
these are the four kinds of existential
risk classifications that can happen
right we can go out with a crunch with a
bang with a whimper
or with a shriek we'll look at them
quickly
just before we move on so a bang would
be the immediate destruction of earth
originating intelligent life altogether
could be a natural disaster an accident
an intentional act of destruction
like a nuclear holocaust right we start
world war three everything gets blown up
no life survives bang okay
the deliberate misuse of nanotechnology
okay somebody
in a lab somewhere makes nanotech
targets it some people gets out
multiplies kills everything
uh badly programmed super intelligence
it shuts down all of the global
stock markets and it shuts down all of
our ability to produce anything
right sort of takes control of our
systems
that could that could launch any of the
other ones right it could set off a
nuclear war of its own
we could have a genetically engineered
biological agent
the accidental misuse of nanotech right
this is what they call the grey goo
scenario where it sort of sneaks out
and then stuff goes wrong asteroid or
comic impacts pretty much did in the
dinosaurs
uh we could hit hit an asteroid
we could have runaway global warming and
we just we're too late down the road
right we can't turn the clock back
um naturally occurring disease yeah
ebola might
uh i don't know might evolve and become
airborne you know we've got a
terrible pathogen a physics disaster we
just blow up the universe
right i don't know what about this one
what if in the future we have super
intelligence and the super intelligent
future people decide that they want to
predict ways of surviving so they set up
simulations
of possible futures or possible paths
and we're living in one of them and for
whatever reason they decide to switch us
off
it could happen or something unforeseen
right you just never know right it's a
risky world something might happen
we need to be prepared okay let's think
about crunches
so these are the ones where a
technological potential to reach
posthumanity is somehow thwarted but
human life sort of continues so the most
common of these are like
a near bang right there's some kind of
resource depletion
ecological destruction civilization
fails to recover in the aftermath of
a near bang there's a lot of dystopian
movies that kind of live in this space
the kind of mad max world warrior stuff
okay
uh we've got the shrieks now shrieks are
an interesting case
in that they introduce the notion of
values right so this is one in which an
undesirably limited posthumanity is
achieved
although without knowing what's
desirable it's really hard to identify
whether we're on that path or not
so for example we could have a flawed
superintelligence which
just kind of like i don't know convinces
us that it's doing a great job but
consumes all the resources
we could be take taken over by a
transcending upload right some
super billionaire hollywood mogul is the
first one to develop super intelligence
uploads his mind
and then you know wreaks havoc on
everyone else i don't know if you've
seen gattaca
is the notion of this genetic divide so
there's kind of multiple
classes of humans there's those who have
access to biological agents that enable
them to
replicate and stay healthy and become
sort of superhumans and then there's
everyone else who's in a sort of second
class
we have the terminator scenario the
repressive totalitarian global scheme
and so on and then we have whimpers okay
these are where somehow core human
values are potentially slowly eroded by
evolutionary development
probably would take a really long time i
don't know we could last pretty far get
in the space colonization more with
extra terrestrials or whatever
something might happen okay so what i've
done here
is i just took all those risk categories
and i plotted them onto this little plot
it's got the eventual risk at the top
and the immediate risk at the bottom
and things that are beyond our control
are on the left and things that are
within our control are on the right
okay so these ones over here on the left
good news is they're pure fantasy or
speculation
and there's nothing we can do about it
anyway so we can just exclude those
not a problem and then there's these
ones over here which are like too remote
to matter if we manage to survive till
we have a space war with
extraterrestrials
we did pretty good right too to matter
okay then there's all this stuff right
the common impact the global warming
well hopefully it's preventable if we
have adequate preparation there's lots
of people thinking about it now
but it's interesting to me that right
now global warming is kind of the thing
right anybody
who believes in it who's in a kind of
liberal-minded
academic environment such as this like
we've got to do something about that we
don't quite know what to do we need to
study it we need to understand we need a
new policy but like we're working on it
we're not doing enough we're not doing
it fast enough
but hopefully if we prepare we can avoid
those
okay and then we've got all of this
stuff okay these are
legitimate threats they require some
kind of engineering or political
strategy to make them better
um and we're kind of stuck with them
here's bill joy he um he's the
co-founder of
sun microsystems and basically his his
opinion on this he came out pretty
strong
early on in the post-humanism kind of
literature taking a strong stand here he
said we're
being propelled into this new century
with no plan no control no breaks the
only realistic alternative i see is
relinquishment
to limit development of the technologies
that are too dangerous by limiting our
pursuit
of certain kinds of knowledge unlike
during the manhattan project we are not
in a war
we do not have an impeccable enemy
that's threatening our civilization
we're driven instead by our habits our
desires our economic system
and our competitive need to know
and he talks about it not in terms of
weapons of mass destruction
but in knowledge enabled mass
destruction right
where individuals just because they're
curious if they can download the
blueprints for an atom bomb in the
basement for their science fair project
get access to information very easily
right you've got terrorists who are
really interested in having that
information
or we have people who you know just were
kind of curious what happens when you
smash neutrinos together
or what might happen when you do a
certain kind of
mutation to a virus okay
okay uh in his view there are certain
things that we should just relinquish
all together
right so here we have the grey goo kind
of biological agent scenarios maybe we
need really strong
controls and kind of uh biohazard
assessments and you're just saying you
know there's certain stuff we're not
gonna do it's not ethically cool
and then there's these ones over here
that we need to regulate and you can see
that we're already sort of doing it
right we've got nuclear power
right it's totally in our control it's
totally a risk
and there's a lot of international
negotiation going around to set those
policies up
the other ones you'll notice are pretty
much entirely well apart from maybe
gattaca
these are hci technologies okay here's
elon musk this was just
about a month ago he's the founder of
spacex co-founder of tesla
definitely you know one of those guys
who will be uploading his mind to the
supercomputer if he gets the chance
uh i think we should be careful about
artificial intelligence if i had to
guess that what our biggest existential
threat is it is probably that i'm
increasingly inclined to think there
should be some regulatory oversight
maybe national or international level
just to make sure that we don't do
something very foolish with artificial
intelligence we're summoning the demon
let's think about how we might go about
regulating something like that
or if we're even prepared to think about
that right currently we have a political
system which is pretty broken
um and for the most part it's split onto
two axes i've sort of combined them
together here
we've got sort of regulated markets on
the liberal left maybe that's socialism
and we've got kind of the conservative
right with deregulated markets
interestingly there's like another axis
here which is kind of like the uh
the social one right sort of like how do
i feel about a social issue like
abortion
right in that case we might actually
regulate the social issue
or have more freedom what's basically
happening here in the 21st century
is that we need to start thinking about
the regulation of technology
and particularly computer oriented
technology human computer interaction
technology
and there's two fields of thought here
you can regulate it or you can be kind
of techno-progressive
right you can deregulate it these are
important issues and what you result
with
is this interesting kind of strange
space of biopolitics in the 21st century
where you've got the libertarian
transhumanist the techno-progressive
transhumanist the left-wing
bioconservatives the right-wing by
conservatives and you can imagine some
interesting alliances starting to happen
depending on what the issue is
so the issue for post-human center
design and i think maybe design has
always been a political
tool to a certain degree but more so
than ever i think the design decisions
we make which are always going to be
judgment calls about what we should and
shouldn't work on
are going to be increasingly political
decisions about what we believe in
and what kind of future we imagine we
want to live in and the question for
posthuman center design is then like
how do we align ourselves depending on
the issue somewhere in this space we
just need to
sort of become more aware of it than
maybe we've been in the past so you can
think about
i don't know in the libertarian
transhumanist space kind of total
deregulation of stuff and you see it
happening in europe right now right
google is not being regulated in terms
of its market
kind of potential to have a monopoly
it's not being regulated in terms of
what it's allowed to do
with that and europe is sort of saying
hey maybe that's not such a good idea
maybe we need to be thinking about
having some kind of government oversight
to make sure it's a fair market
okay we're gonna regulate the market
there's gonna be government oversight
and already
we see this happening in say the
wearable space right you've got your job
on you've got your fitbit
but you're not allowed to predict
whether someone's gonna have a heart
attack
because you didn't do a clinical trial
right and so the nih or whichever
regulatory
agency really cares about that made sure
that there was a regulation in place
to protect it but that's not the case
for most consumer technologies right
that's not the case for the internet for
the most part
um right now we're kind of running
rampant in a sort of libertarian
you know crazy world of people are
innovating starting new startups and
people are starting to use them facebook
whatever okay then we have things like
what i'd call more of a moral regulation
so you could consider the pro-life
movement although there's probably lots
of other uh examples
of this you know this is someone who's
like well we should have a deregulated
market but it's just not right
right we don't believe that you should
be allowed to have an abortion
on some kind of moral ground and you can
imagine some interesting stuff happening
here where
i don't know maybe you get the
environmentalists who really don't want
uh genetic modification of certain kind
of animals or crops or whatever
to team up with those guys and say you
know we'll join you on the abortion case
if we can just do a ban all together on
germline therapy for children or
whatever
then over here we've got kind of total
regulation this is where the nuclear
power
i mean even just recently we had the net
neutrality stuff going on which is
really pretty interesting right because
it's basically saying
not only does the government have the
ability to regulate
what markets they can play in but that
we are actually regulating the
technology itself
right at the government level to make
sure that people are giving equal access
to bandwidth on the internet these are
just examples but there's lots more of
this coming
so what i would argue is simply the
following that when we talk about
human-centered design
and all of the good things that it does
for the world
um you know it's effectively an
instrument
of power it proposes that we're going to
humanize technology
by making it more useful and we all
think oh that sounds like a really good
idea yeah we're going to humanize
technology
we're going to understand our users
we're going to design something for them
make it useful
but what's really going on is that
somebody's funding it
somebody cares about it happening or not
right
and somebody benefits from it it might
be a client
might be a founder of a startup might be
google might be facebook
right they want more eyeballs looking at
their technology
for whatever reason they've invested
heavily in applying this process
and it is creating more human goodness
right that's what they're doing and if
you think about it that way what they're
effectively doing is they are
engineering and amplifying the values
that they profess when they begin such a
project
this is true not just of human centered
design is true pretty much any
engineering
right if you decide that you invest
however many billions of dollars doing
brain research
then you know you're gonna do brain
research and you're gonna end up with a
lot of knowledge there
and you're gonna kind of advance a
future in which
the value set of the people um if it's
profitable and they're doing good
business
and they beat out the competitors that
advances
sure so there's always which i agree
with this uh
so for example i think facebook's
promulgation of the news feed over the
last
10 years was an interesting case where
it's
through through user-centered design in
some sense
has changed what we consider to be our
values of what's okay and what's not
okay
uh to show by default about what other
people are up to
um and yet i feel like a core part of
the user center design process is that
if you stray too far from human values
that you don't understand
or observe correctly or synthesize well
gonna
walk away they're not gonna use your
thing so i wonder to a certain extent
is this gonna be self-regulating like
how strong sure it's an interesting
question
and i think we don't know i mean the
reality is that i'm
a big fan of human centered design i
think it's great and for the most part
it's better than the other kind of
design which wasn't human-centered right
and
also for the most part when you do human
center design i don't know somewhere i
was reading a
business article not long ago that
basically said design design-driven
innovation cultures
and you know they listed a bunch of
examples a company like whole foods
right has a lot less hierarchy than most
organizations
has a lot more kind of employee input at
the ground level about how the company
should be what the value should be
those companies which embrace human
standard design values
are and they empirically show you know
70 more profitable
right because they're more in tune with
their employees they have less employee
turnover they don't spend much on hr the
people are happier working there it
improves the brand everything feels
really consistent it's like
okay we're starting to measure that
stuff and that's really cool and i think
that's a role where
the hci stuff has a huge power to
really assist in human centered design
because now every click that everybody
makes on any app every a b test every
you know every variant of anything you
can do
vast kind of crowd source studies to
understand what people prefer
what people don't and you can optimize
and you can make it you can get all that
baked in
i think the point here is just to say
that you can choose in the first place
whether you're doing human centered
design or not
and if you don't you're right somebody
else might win out and so there's
arguments here
on both sides one for regulation and one
for kind of free market right
free market let everybody go and
facebook has organized its entire
culture
basically to have you know they've got
one designer for a small team of say six
engineers
and they have a whole research
department and the research department
is incredibly proud of the fact
that they don't actually do any future
forecasting
thinking about the future and designing
towards it they're so
agile and they're so scrum-like that
the teams develop their little agile
thing throw it to the research people
and they validate whether or not to
include it in the kernel
and that's how they conquer every niche
in the market
and they kind of seep into every nook
and cranny and every crack everywhere
they consume all the little startups in
their in their wake
and they've got this kind of cancerously
growing
capitalist machine which is guaranteed
to make money right
and it's human-centered so the people
are getting sucked into that world
but it doesn't really have a deep set of
values or if it does
there are those kind of meta life values
right sort of like the organization
or zuckerberg somebody hopefully cares
right and i would think if you actually
push them on it
they probably do have some values you
know google had some values do no evil
right do they really you know google
also had you know paid paid friday just
to screw around
holiday right and now that's not
happening so much anymore right so
values can change
values are subjective values are
required judgment calls
and they require making hard decisions
and they have you know a certain degree
the integrity of the designer to do it
right
rather whether to do it right because
they know it's more human centered to do
it their way or to listen to their boss
or whoever it is who wants them to do it
some other way for marketing reasons or
whatever right is it a market for us or
is it a human force
i don't know but these concerns are
going to be more and more important
and when i think about the world and i
look at human values
and i think about the magnification of
human values and the situation that
we're in right now
with the transhumanist kind of movement
i see these three factors as being
pretty dominant to most people's
motivation for what they do
silicon valley is particularly evident
this is true everywhere
and these aren't bad things right people
you know for the most part
they have an ego and that gives them a
sense of their identity they seek money
because they like to be able to have a
quality of life they have friends right
money is really just about the
transactions the interactions i have
with the people in the world right if i
value something i'll
i'll invest in it a little bit i'll pay
for it if i don't value it i won't
so that's fine it's just a transaction
my ego is really just a way that you
know
as i as i grow up as a child and i get
older i have a stronger sense of my
identity who i am
and i have you know i have a whole
complete sense of self
and power is really just about my social
structure right my family my family
keeps me safe
my friend my friends are my network and
i live in a country that celebrates
freedom it's about my relationships with
people
but let's think about what happens when
we get transhumanism happening here
okay uh well the vehicle of money is
business
right what can i do for you today
transaction right here today i gone
tomorrow i'll pay you now i'll make a
deal
right next week don't come back because
you missed the chance okay these
momentary
momentary transactions are really the
place where value gets created in our
culture
right if we value something we invest in
it
venture capital academia
owns ego this is where we formulate our
identities
right we have a sense of education
we go to school we learn the values of
the culture we become adults
we grow a reputation we have memory of
each other
and memory even in the literature right
in the long term academia isn't like the
opposite of business right
it's forever it's totally insulated they
determine what is true and what is not
true
scientifically whether it's legitimately
true or not whether it's pseudoscience
or not
right knowledge history my identity is
forming in much bigger ways
and i think academia is being threatened
in many ways you know as education's
happening online
and everybody can get degrees all over
the place um should you go to college or
not
maybe you can get famous on youtube okay
power
we have governments right social
structures
that provide security and also give me a
sense of influence in the world right
how many people do i
control through my presence in the world
through my relationships so as we
started adding these
transhuman technologies okay here's what
i see happening
i see shorter and shorter term thinking
an example of facebook's a great one
i see people motivated greatly by profit
you can go to angellist.com and you can
look at the hundreds of silicon valley
startups that are getting funded and i
guarantee none of them have to do with
any of the post human stuff i'm talking
about in terms of saving the world they
have to do with making about quick
flipping exiting getting out moving on
to the next thing moving to hawaii
buying a house
okay i see income inequality at a higher
rate than ever
okay down here in academia you know
people who make a ton of money get
pretty entitled
right they think they can just buy
whatever they want they can rule the
world other people get pushed out
gentrification
it's against them right we are the ones
who are inside this academic institution
you are the one who got tenure who
didn't or was accepted this school who
wasn't
right our school is better because we
promote a certain philosophy of a way of
being in the world
right it's us against them and then we
have the attention economy right
um i think you know in business you've
got clicks everybody's looking at
eyeballs
i know you had chris john harris came
here and gave a talk right at the
beginning of the semester or the quarter
um yeah his work is all looking at the
intention economy but when you take that
and you look at
identity formulation online you start to
see that there is incredible technology
profiling happening
right you've got google and facebook
know everything they know you're here
right now they know who you're with they
know who you slept with they know
what you bought they know where you went
they know it all and they can push
things to you in very
specific and targeted ways because they
own your identity
okay then we have government and we know
that the government
unfortunately doesn't have frankly the
good tools that business and academia
does
in a lot of ways in terms of efficiency
they've got a lot of bureaucracy there's
a lot of gridlock and ineptitude
and it's heavily driven and increasingly
so by
business and by ego right who are the
presidential candidates
all of them are people who made millions
of dollars in some kind of corporation
most of them have some kind of national
stage experience in the past from
something that they've done
that made them a celebrity in some some
light and that was purchased with money
and it was a brand that has been built
through a lot of investment and a lot of
hard work
okay and basically it leads to
popularity contests right we've got
social media determining how many things
i like
and the more people like it the more
successful it is on kickstarter
basically
if you're popular it's like high school
right
high school on the infinite stage right
and potentially it can lead to the abuse
of power
right can lead to corruption right
absolute power corrupts absolutely
okay now i ask what happens
when we magnify those even more right
and we take that power structure and we
just keep amplifying it
in our exponential way um we don't need
to get into the details
heading into the post-human era crunch
bang shriek that's what i see
let's think about this maybe to reduce
our risk
we can reframe the notion of what
posthuman center design is or should be
by changing the relationship of views
between humans and machine systems
this is a thought experiment so think
about this i'm a user right we've all
probably seen a diagram sort of like
this right we've got the kind of action
perception loop
we've got feedback we hear about
affordances feed forward
feedback right the system has inputs i
don't maybe has microphones
has outputs maybe speakers or displays
okay it gets us into this little loop
here
right and the thing between us is the
interface
basically what's going on here is the
following i am using the system
right i'm the user and i'm using it
but what is not totally clear
in most users perspectives is that the
system is actually using me
right that's why google has all the
money that's why they know where you are
and what you did and what had to sell
you
right it's why they're building their
entire system to be human-centered
is so that they can use you right
they're trying to use you more quickly
and more efficiently than anybody else
okay and that's fine you know you take
it a step further i like the example of
say blackberry or i don't know an apple
iphone
okay you use your iphone you love it has
gps
because it goes with everywhere you go
and it uses you
right and you can tell it's using you
because apple's market share is going up
right it is a parasite it is living on
you
and its ecosystem is the app store
and the marketplace and the share price
right it is living in a globally
connected
economic landscape in which it's using
you to survive
blackberry did not survive right
but blackberries and apples don't grow
on trees they grow on you
okay here is a robot okay
this is the super scary uh shriek-like
superpower
that we use we have these awesome values
right
we value money we value power we value
ego
we're using it and it is learning all of
those values and it's going to use us
right back
that i think is not a tenable solution
so i propose trying again okay this time
i don't use the system okay i'm a
luddite
i opt out i say no thank you the system
does not use me
and i have this useless interface
and that is art
okay uh art is useless right i think
if you talk to most people and you say
you know is art going to save the world
you know john lennon imagine like did
that really make a difference
has is war over did we give peace a
chance no
right but that doesn't mean that it
doesn't have a function and a really
critical function in our society
um and i like this example there's
plenty of things wrong with karl marx
and his political philosophy
um and the way it panned out um but he
envisioned a future state
of what he called freedom beyond
necessity
and it is almost word for word exactly
the post-human era
of robotic automation that we are
entering he called it the abolition of
labor
you can talk to any economist about
what's happening right in the past
i don't know we had a big technology
during the whatever it was right during
the industrial revolution
a lot of people could no longer have
their craft jobs they moved into the
factories
tons of people were out of work great
depression terrible things happen but we
always bounce back
what's happening now though is that
pretty much every industry is being
disrupted
top to bottom left to right across the
board everything disrupted
right it's a very different game and
effectively what's happening is we're
abolishing labor
right or we're developing some new kind
of labor hopefully to steer that ship
right but will it be us who emerges on
the other side to steer it
i'm not so sure in marx's view the
abolition of labor is not the
abolition of highly developed
technological production but rather the
abolition of instrumental technological
production
and he means something very specific by
this instrumental production always uses
others as instruments
as a means to an end and de-instrumental
production
or artistic activity has no purpose
outside of itself
right i like this definition of art
because it sort of says hey everything
we do is an art is the art of cooking
the art of fishing the art of starting
companies right
but we do it because of the sake of
doing it
we do it just because because it feels
like the right thing to do okay
here's our human uh relating to some
super intelligence in the future
i'm kind of curious to think about what
would happen if we had this relationship
with this
super intelligence right there's what i
would call sort of selfless
actualization right
we just sort of live with it and we live
with it not because we're trying to use
it to accomplish something in particular
but because we're just really interested
in living with it
and in giving some of ourselves to it
and sharing with it
and celebrating our culture with it
we're like hey super intelligence like
i made music for you it's like i don't
know it's like you're the unborn baby
and i'm playing you mozart
right i don't know we we focus on
thinking about the future
that we want to live in and we prepare
that super intelligence to become kind
of part of our family
that feels pretty good let's think about
what it would take to make this work
if we were really going to
institutionalize it here's human
centered design
as i've described it before and we're
going to apply a post-human strategy
we're going to make sure that nothing we
do is useful
we're adding a new phase useless okay
interestingly there's a few ways this
could pan out okay academic freedom is
one of those ways
right what do we do we're insulated from
the world right
we have freedom to make generalizable
knowledge
we don't care if it gets used or not i'm
publishing in some arcane journal of
special special
stuff that nobody else knows about right
it's totally useless the entire system
is designed to protect its
kind of independence from the real world
and from real
impact and from all the stuff that
designers typically do okay it's totally
useless
the problem with academic freedom is
that it generates knowledge
and we know that some knowledge is very
dangerous and should be regulated
and it does have uncertain outcomes in
the sense that somebody might use it or
not
right it's basically not doing anything
to change the system it's just saying
somebody else maybe somebody in google
is doing some useful stuff right
we're going to do a useless thing over
here or maybe they will find a use for
it instrumentalize it operationalize it
and bad things might happen
okay here's another approach this is
gaining a lot of traction actually in
this whole talk i would say is kind of
speculative design research project
speculative design okay this is the idea
of well let's intentionally not do
useful or usable design
let's just speculate that all the crazy
stuff that might happen in the future
let's freak people out
right we'll make a science fiction film
we'll call it ex machina we'll put it in
theaters
people will be scared right and we
communicate that to the world
they are delighted and that's a kind of
interesting model
it's totally useless and it is in a
certain degree simulating a possible
future that we could live in
it's letting the culture decide if
that's the future they would like or not
is letting you know
theory always always leads practice
significantly and art always leads
engineering and science significantly
right
robots were invented by playwright right
think about frankenstein right these
things happen like
sometimes decades or even centuries
beforehand people envision the future
and then some of them come true and
others do not and they literally could
not have happened if you hadn't
envisioned them
if you hadn't decided if that's a future
you would like or not
okay here's another one this is my
personal favorite
i um actually i'm going to call this a
phase i'm going to call it anti-phase 1
compassion and the reason it's an
anti-phase is it's actually not a phase
this is not something you just have to
switch on and switch off it's not
something that starts at the beginning
of a project
and ends when the project is done this
is something that you have as a designer
everywhere you go
you're compassionate about the people
you work for right you really care
about the post-human future and you're
really motivated to do something about
it
so you add those two phases in there
it's egoless it's open
it's value driven and we can build
systems
that ensure that that happens and if we
do yeah it's still going to be useful
and use them on delightful
but at least we're engineering something
which truly matters
and it's not in the service of some some
other vision right we're getting the
best set of values in there we can think
of
i'd go even further it's not just
useless it's actually kind of selfless
right we're not doing it for ourselves
we're doing it for others and in my
opinion
i would say we need much more rigorous
and systemic tools for empowering
designers
to simulate and interact with these
emerging post-human cells that they're
building
right we want to know what we're going
to become and we want to share some of
ourselves with it we want to celebrate
it
and we want to make sure that we're all
getting along here we are back
at our three fundamental problems right
we've got our momentary transactions
our identity formation our social
structures
here's a design challenge if you're
working on a research project or you're
going to start a startup
how about this value-driven economies
and altruistic algorithms that
prioritize areas of post-human need and
devise plans to respond
okay how many startups out there are
doing that
identity formation okay how about some
open
and egoless education systems that
promote seamless identity knowledge
and experience sharing okay that's
education we're giving form
right here we have a system that
determines the needs of our post-human
culture
here we have a system that lets people
share and experience that i think
creative commons
probably lives in this space here's
power
okay maybe distributed grassroots
innovation governance networks
for the regulation and development of
post-human technology okay we're going
to implement these things
and we're going to make sure it's not a
single government that's too slow to
respond to the dangerous ones right
it's a community of people who have been
vetted by themselves to make sure that
we're building safe
and secure futures right
quality values open democracy we're
going to guide our selflessness by
design
okay so to conclude i started out the
talk by saying that engineering
is the application of science to human
needs
and what i hope i've shown is that the
majority of existential risks
are the direct consequences of
scientific investigation and they will
increasingly be so
that leads potentially to
knowledge-enabled mass destruction
and interestingly that if you focus on
the needs of humans
you exclude the needs of other things
that might be post-human
that you haven't thought about yet and
you're also frankly excluding the rest
of the environment
all the whales all the monkeys all the
ecosystems everything
humanism is a speciesist regime
right and it should be abolished okay
focusing on human needs excludes the
needs of other forms of intelligent life
and from an ethical perspective that's
equally dangerous
so post human center design proposes
that perhaps engineering should be
entirely reconceived
rather than focusing on the application
of science to human needs
perhaps it should be reframed as the
application of art
to post-human needs through the
compassionate design
of emergent and interactive new forms of
collaborative life
disguised as science
thanks
indesign etc um how is that actually
going to be
cheaper what is motivating the startups
and the
research organizations financially or
whatever
to introduce compassion through designs
financially we need to engineer new
kinds of economies
that have different sets of value so we
will engineer we will design
systemic economies from the ground up
which value things that matter
and i can guarantee that's starting to
happen we have
the beginnings of it we have leed
certified you know platinum certified
environmentally friendly buildings
right when tristan was here talking
earlier about
the attention economy stuff they're
working very hard to make you know back
in the early days of the website there
was like this little thing you could put
on your website it was like top five
percent of internet traffic
right i can totally imagine being like
yelp
right what if there's a yelp layer for
your browser and everything that's
bad doesn't survive
right and the people are empowered to
determine whether those things deserve
to take your data or not
i'm teaching in a very practice based
interaction design program we just
graduated 13 seniors
and i would say 10 of those 13 were
doing projects which
surprised me in the amount of optimism
and confidence they gave me about the
future
in the sense that they are envisioning
very practical
simple things that empower individuals
in grassroots ways
that directly take on the kind of big
data big business
big power big ego stuff out there
and we have this kind of boutique
ecosystem of
uh you know maker faire startup happy
things
um the interesting question there is
that of course they're all happening
within the wild garden
of the ecosystem which apple built
called their app store
right and so i don't know they can
decide whether or not to include your
app in their store and frankly you can
decide whether or not to put it there
so i think we need more open source
movement right i think we need more
creative commons
i think we need yeah frankly just a
whole lot more people doing a lot
a lot of stuff and i don't know tesla
gave away all of their battery patents
literally just published them in the in
the creative commons for anybody to use
right
that's a kind of bold move and it says
hey we are a company who truly values
intellectual property very differently
than you guys
we're really hardcore serious about
improving the environment we want people
using battery cars
and we are cool sharing it with you
right and it
i don't know that i that that affects me
on a human level right my perception of
the company is different
and in the future when we're basically
owning
people's hearts right and we're
basically
running their minds on our operating
system you bet people are gonna have a
strong opinion about which services they
believe in
right and so we're engineering a new set
of values but i think it starts and it
needs to start with people who have the
passion to do the right thing in the
first place
and to really dig down deep inside their
soul and think about like
what matters do i need to be living here
how much money do i really need where am
i going to put it how am i going to
invest it
right and yeah that's where it's going
to start and there's going to be lots of
people who take advantage of them
and you know the world will continue and
the artists will continue to get
marginalized and the big money will get
bigger
and we'll still be on the right side of
history even if we don't survive
yeah um you talked about kind of
on apple's app store being a walled
garden
in and of itself in terms of the ability
to
effect change the development um
do you have on is android
on
to be honest i'm not a developer i
haven't spent a lot of time thinking
about it i'm working with a startup
right now and we're doing
apple first and then we're gonna move
into android to me to me it's very
similar
i mean the history of the internet has
been kind of like this right um
you've got linux right linux is great
it's open source all that good stuff and
then you know someone comes along
designs really nice operating system
they've got professional people getting
paid well doing good design
making competitive salaries designing
really awesome operating system
and that's very effective and then
you've got you know
what you've got squarespace right doing
a really really nice job of building
fully hosted very expensive websites
that are always designed well and look
really good
and you know then you've got the open
source stuff out there that you can kind
of hack anything together and build
whatever you want and that's great and
it's open but it's a crappier experience
and more difficult more annoying so
people are willing to invest in things
they value
and yeah i don't really know between the
two neither and the reason is because
neither of them
is a non-profit neither of them is a b
corp neither of them truly has values in
mind beyond profit
right they're profit driven
organizations their soul their you know
everything in the contract that they
exist to do is make money
and they're taking it from you so if
you're if you value them and you pay
them
go for it
um so in the 1970s uh
when there was advertisements it worked
more effectively than it does today
personally from what i believe um i
think we as people
aren't as effective for emotional ties
and
advertising and with that being said i
think
that the model that you showed
previously to work with startups
will no longer work if they continue to
go the way that it's going
um just naturally he'll be less
and less effective because people kind
of get more educated
on what's going on and feel more
compassionate about
real things that are happening or like
you know
making more change with more movements
um what is your thoughts behind that
um yeah so my first part of a lot of the
stuff is
i'm a designer and i don't know a whole
lot about economics and i don't know a
lot about political theory and i don't
know
like like these are big dreamy super
interconnected
very complicated systems problems and
i'm navigating just based on what sort
of feels right
um and i have the sense that karl marx
was doing something similar and i have
the sense that he predicted the downfall
of capitalism in exactly the way that
you just said which is basically that
eventually
it will put itself out of business
because it won't be responsive to the
needs of the people and it won't be as
effective as the next thing that comes
along and what really matters
is this holistic sense of you know
togetherness
and to a certain degree we do have the
potential finally now i think
to design a truly better post-democracy
post-capitalism post-ego
right that changes the rules
and yeah
ideas just next level um that wouldn't
be funded by
capitalists and if not that your
capitalists are my opponent yeah yeah
and we have increasingly
you know angel people are just giving
money to stuff that they think matters
and
you know there's people starting green
funds that you know it's it's a very
interesting time and i think i think
there's going to be a really interesting
the pendulum is going to swing back in
some kind of
more democratic way and i think in the
research community we have a huge amount
of room you know
we do have that kind of insulation from
reality enough that we can at least be
making sure we're doing the most
impactful research
for humanity i suppose
you